en una entrevista con la radio pública
el primer ministro jan castex adelantó
parte de las medidas que formarán parte
de ese protocolo sanitario del regreso a
clases y el trabajo que será anunciado
mañana en conferencia de prensa pero en
general dijo con respecto al aumento de
los casos que habido los últimos días
que no hay que asustarse que la
situación no es como la que vivimos en
abril y mayo sin embargo dijo no quiere
decir que el virus haya perdido su
fuerza con respecto a en general a este
protocolo dijo que el gobierno está
haciendo todo para que los franceses
puedan retomar a partir de septiembre su
vida normal y se refirió a la polémica
sobre las mascarillas en colegios y
liceos
recordemos que serán exigidas y
obligatorias a los niños mayores de 11
años dijo que el gobierno no va a pagar
las mascarillas de todos los alumnos
sino sólo de aquellos que tengan la
necesidad económica con respecto al
trabajo recordemos también que las
mascarillas serán exigidas en las
empresas ya en castell dijo que él está
por seguir estimulando el trabajo a
distancia que ha perdido su mala
reputación durante el confinamiento
también anunció que las mascarillas
serán obligatorias en cines
y reconoció que la aplicación de
seguimiento de los enfermos stop kobe no
ha dado los resultados esperados con
respecto al esperado plan de
relanzamiento económico que debía ser
anunciado esta semana el primer ministro
confirmó que lo será la próxima semana